es hört sich so an als ob die richtig
lust habt euren staffel für streicher
eine neue frisur zu verfassen also
schnappen wir uns unsere gartenscheren
und gehen raus in den garten und
schneiden unsere stachelbeere sträucher
los geht's filmstar werden schneiden ist
es natürlich ganz wichtig dass du
erstmal handschuh anziehst wenn sonst
kann das ziemlich aktiv sind und
ansonsten ist die pflege von
stachelbeeren eigentlich ziemlich
ähnlich wie bei den johannisbeeren die
größte unterschied ist dass ich ganz
gerne das obere drittel der längsten
triebe abschneiden ansonsten auch immer
die sträucher gut auslichten krank ist
und schwaches holz entfernen und auch
alle triebe die sich kreuzen oder die
sich irgendwie im weg sind raus nehmen
auch erste die horizontal wachsen nimmst
du raus weil sich die sonst oft auf die
erde senken und den bären dann im dreck
hängen und am ende sollte dann strauch
dann so aufgebaut sein dass du zwei
einjährige triebe hast 22 jährige triebe
23 jährige triebe und 24 jährige triebe
wenn den strauch noch jünger als 34
jahre alt ist dann hast du natürlich
noch keine älteren triebe aber ab einem
alter von vier jahren seite der straße
ungefähr so aufgebaut sein wenn du dich
frage ist wie alt denn welche triebe
sind dann schau sie dir einfach mal ganz
genau an
weil je älter ein trieb ist desto dicker
ist natürlich und desto dunkler ist auch
die rinde und wenn du dir deine pflanzt
einfach mal ganz genau anschaut dann
wirst du denke ich ganz gut
unterscheiden können
wie alt welche betriebe sind im video zu
den johannisbeeren habe ich euch ja
schon erklärt dass es wichtig ist die
beerensträucher zu schneiden damit sie
einen besseren ertrag abwerfen und schön
große beeren produzieren können wenn man
die stachelbeeren schneidet kann man
sich eigentlich aussuchen das kann man
entweder im sommer direkt nach der ernte
machen also dann kannst du dir auch
dieses video hier anschauen und das
genauso bei dir im garten umsetzen oder
eben jetzt bei uns ist es jetzt gerade
märz und im februar und märz kann man
die stachelbeeren auch wunderbar
schneiden bevor sie richtig austreiben
im winter für nächste immer noch ein
bisschen einfacher weil man da nicht die
blätter im weg hat und viel leichter
sehen kann wieder strauch aufgebaut ist
und dann besser überlegen kann welches
man eher wegnimmt und welche bleiben
sollen stachelbeeren reagieren übrigens
sehr empfindlich auf trockenheit stress
also gerade in sehr heißen trockenen
sommern daleiden die richtig da er so
schon ab und zu mal zur gießkanne
greifen gerade bei pflanzen die
vielleicht noch nicht hundertprozentig
angewachsen sehen aber was den boden
auch richtig schön feucht hält ist eine
dicke mulchschicht
da kannst du entweder hinten wo ich
verwenden oder holzhackschnitzel reden
mich bitte nicht auf die gemüsebeete
ausbringen die frage kommen so ziemlich
unter jedem einer videos rein finden
sich eignet sich nicht für gemüse da
holzhackschnitzel nehmen das ist der
gesamte baum der gewechselt wird und
nicht nur die rinde aber für
beerensträucher ist das wunderbar da
könnt ihr auch rindenmulch verwenden
wenn ihr welchen da habt da richtig
schön dickmilch auf den kreis um die
pflanze drumrum ausbringen das
unterdrückt die gräser die da wachsen
hält den boden schön feucht verrottet
nach und nach und ihr könnt jetzt auch
bevor ihr den wohlig aus bringt noch
eine kompost schicht um die pflanzen
verteilen oder die mit einem
biologischen flüssigdünger dingen damit
sie gut gewappnet sind für die neue
gartensaison da drüben findest du mein
video zum johannisbeeren schneiden schau
dir das auf jeden fall ein wenn du davon
auch ein paar in deinem garten stehen
hast ansonsten sehen wenn es am samstag
wieder mit einem neuen video macht's gut